Speaker 1: Let's go next to Frumpies from
Chicago, from BESE.
You're on the air.
From there, you're on the air, how are you?
Speaker 3: Tonight, thank you so I saw some
other countries are testing out a four day
workweek, have you heard of that?
Speaker 1: Yep, we covered that on the bonus
show last week.
Speaker 3: OK, so I'm thinking that some states
in the US should try this, and I've seen some
justifications stating things like, well,
the five day workweek was based on one family
member and the typical household staying home
and taking care of things, one person being
the breadwinner.
So I was just wondering what you were thinking
of the justifications to move to a four day
work week?
I've heard of the productivity, but I just
thought to get your comments on.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: What do you what do you when you
say states should try it, do you mean states
should mandate that businesses only have people
work for days?
You mean like state employees should do it?
Speaker 3: That's a good distinction, I was
thinking it was just a labor law within a
certain state.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's never going to happen.
But let's let's put that aside.
I mean, it's not going to happen anytime soon.
Let's put that aside.
Here's why I think for four day a week is
very interesting.
There's a real difference between having two
days off versus three days off a week.
And when you have the three days off and you've
got that middle day where you were off yesterday
and you're off tomorrow, I think that psychologically
there's a massive benefit to that.
And the benefit to that is that then people
are more productive on the four days that
they are working, even if in total they're
working slightly fewer hours.
We've sort of adopted this at The David Pakman
Show and that we film our five shows each
week in four days.
So like we're not off on Friday, but it's
sort of like a catch up administrative work.
You know, everybody has the stuff we work
on on Fridays, but like the core filming is
all happening four days a week.
And I know for me psychologically, when we're
done on Thursday, it's like, oh, I'm not doing
like a core filming day Friday, Saturday or
Sunday.
That's really great.
And I think it makes me significantly more
productive Monday, Monday through Thursday.
If I had child care considerations, I think
it would be significantly more convenient
and also cheaper from the standpoint of child
care.
If I have three days and then my significant
other has three days, I think that there's
significant benefits there.
But yeah, I don't think there's anything magical
about a five day a week work week.
And the study that we looked at last week
on the bonus show was very positive as far
as that goes.
Speaker 3: Mm hmm.
OK, well, God knows I could use another day.
Thanks for taking my call.
All right.
Producer that's doing OK.
Talk to you later.
Speaker 1: All right.
My pleasure.
Thank you very much.